Speaker 1: We have the unsurprising revelation,
which I've mentioned a half a dozen times in
the last year and a half of the pandemic that
COVID conspiracies are linked to and pushing
people towards anti-Semitism. This shouldn't
really surprise to many people. If you've
been watching this show and we're going to talk
about this new report, which is very interesting,
Technology Review has a summary of the report by
Charlotte, which says COVID conspiracy theories
are driving people to anti-Semitism online.
Old and overtly anti-Semitic fantasies are
gaining new adherents adherents depending on
your preference, and far right activists have
been working to convert anti-lockdown beliefs into
anti-Semitism, too, so it's happening both ways.
A warning Conspiracy theories about COVID are
helping disseminate antisemitic beliefs to a
wider audience, warns a new report by the
anti-racist advocacy group Hope Not Hate.
The report says not only has the pandemic revived
interest in the new world order conspiracy theory
of a secret Jewish run elite that claims that
aims to run the world. But far right activists
have also worked to convert people's anti-lockdown
and anti-vaccine beliefs into active antisemitism.
Worst offenders The authors easily managed to
find anti-Semitism on all nine platforms they
investigated, including Tik Tok, Instagram,
Twitter and YouTube. Some of it uses coded
language to avoid detection and moderation
algorithms. Much of it is overt and discoverable.
Unsurprisingly, the authors found a close link
between the amount of anti-Semitism on a platform
and how lightly or loosely it is
moderated. The laxer, the moderation,
the bigger the problem of anti-Semitism. We've
talked before about how shadow government.
New World Order conspiracy theories have a lot of
different flavors, many of which are anti-Semitic.
We've talked about that for a long time, so
that's one kind of piece of this. But the report,
which is really very much worth looking at, has
an entire section. We're going to link to it
in the description, to the YouTube clip for the
story called Conspiracy Ideologies, COVID 19 and
anti-Semitism. And I would, you know, go through
it. It has a bunch of different ways in which all
of this stuff links to anti-Semitism. One aspect
of this is a lot of new world order. One World
government shadow government COVID conspiracies
are interlinked with widespread and longstanding
antisemitic conspiracies, where the people
doing the shadow government are. The Jews
could be mixed in with the build, the bergs or the
trilateral commission, or it's the Rothschild or,
you know, there's different kind of flavors
of it. But New World Order shadow government
very much linked to antisemitism number two,
sometimes it's just the individuals they blame
are Jewish individuals. Soros is one classic
example. The other aspect of this that we've
seen is the trivialization of the Holocaust in
COVID conspiracies, the wearing of the yellow
stars or of the syringe swastikas that we've seen
floating around. That's been happening a lot and
that's mentioned here. So the article, the report
rather talks about anti-Semitism as a conspiracy
tradition, just like most of these conspiratorial
enclaves have anti-Semitic Jew hatred there.
It specifically talks about these various
trivialization of the Holocaust. It talks about
the role of the internet specifically, and that's
a section that's very much worth looking at.
It talks about the spread of anti-Semitic
conspiracy ideologies during the pandemic in
Europe. It talks about 5G. 5G, you know, again,
you have to understand how all of these tropes
go together, but they have. The Jewish control
of business thing and 5G is a business thing,
and so you have that blending together
quite quite easily. It goes into specific
examples in different countries, and the list
of countries is so long, as you can see here
that I'm not going to read it all to you. And the
other aspect of this is far right recruitment from
the conspiracy scene. So this is just even folks
who fall for one conspiracy theory or another
related to COVID and then end up in these Facebook
groups or different circles, even if they are not
previously anti-Semitic or even link the
COVID stuff to anti-Semitism. The anti-Semitic
right wingers, white nationalist, etc. know
that these are fertile recruiting grounds
for pulling people into the next step. And if
they already have started to believe there's
some kind of one word conspiracy or involving
Soros and bankers and Bill Gates, you know,
whatever. I know Bill Gates isn't Jewish, but
the point is if you're already in that universe
to say, Well, you know, have you noticed that
a lot of the people that are part of this thing
happen to be Jewish? And here's a whole bunch
of other things that Jews are responsible for.
And then also, I mean, I don't I think it's worth
mentioning the idea of Jews as carrying disease
spreading disease, which is a very, very old idea.
So many of us intuitively suspected that there
were there was mixed in right anti-Semitism into
a lot of this stuff. The signals were all there.
Sometimes it's explicit. Sometimes it's implicit.
And here it's sort of like in all of the above
type of scenario. So check out the report from
Hope, not hate. I don't think you'll find anything
particularly shocking if you've been following
anti-Semitism for any period of time. But the
detail with which they break it down and show
you how you know in Albania here is how it's
manifesting versus in the Netherlands, in Spain.
It's taking this other. It has this other flavor
very well done and very interesting. So check
that out. Let me know your thoughts. You can
find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We're
going to take a quick break, and we've got
a tremendous program for you today. All right,
let's keep going, remember that we do depend on
folks like you signing up on our website
to fund the program, to fund staff salaries
and health insurance and all of these
things, I would love for you to sign up
on my website. Join Packman dot com. You get
a bunch of great member benefits, including an
extra show that we do just for our members every
single day. Join Packman dot com is the place.